éditorialiste michel fize michel fize
bienvenue un toujours plaisir de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau alors on vient
d'entendre michelle rodriguez en figures
emblématiques des gilet jaune il a dit
beaucoup beaucoup de choses j'aimerais
revenir avec vous sur une de ces choses
qu'il a dites les gilets jaunes ne sont
pas assez entendu en france est ce que
c'est le cas alors d'abord je crois
qu'il faut rappeler qu'il est important
de donner la parole aux acteurs de ce
mouvement et je crois que sur arte
france on est à peu près les seuls à le
faire chaque chaque samedi alors d'abord
ce mouvement il continue son chemin il a
connu des hauts et des bas mais ils
expriment évidemment une société qui
quoi qu'on dise va mal en fin de compte
dans cette société tout va mal notre
école va mal notre régime politique va
mal notre économie ne va pas si bien que
ça normal qu'après alors je crois que je
crois qu'il est important effectivement
de montrer qu'il ya toujours une france
qui souffre une france qui a du mal
j'avais même dire a commencé les débuts
de mois parce que le problème n'est plus
la fin de mois un parfois au début du
mois on est déjà endetté on ne sait plus
comment comment coco comment faire voilà
donc je crois que au delà des grands
messages de réassurance eh bien on a une
situation qui est inchangé depuis
maintenant cinq ans alors les économies
en ont dit de la france qu'elle serait
landais moteur économique de l'europe
avec ses 7 % de croissance en 2021
n'est-il pas de la contradiction entre
ces bons chiffres économiques et ces
français qui peine à remplir leurs
caddies payer leur loyer et mettre de
l'essence alors il y a deux économies
celle dont on parle est celle dont on ne
parle pas ou peu il y à l'économie des
courbes des statistiques est
effectivement comme vous le rappeliez il
y à cette économie
qui nous parle d'une croissance en
hausse donc effectivement 7% en oubliant
que la dernière c'est à peu près -8%
donc on compense un petit peu et puis
c'est une croissance qui a été alimentée
par les dizaines et dizaines de
milliards qu'on a qu'on a versé au nom
du quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan sur
le plan économique bon mais derrière ces
chiffres il ya une dette abyssale un
plusieurs centaines de milliards 116 %
du produit intérieur intérieur brut
voilà donc on a un endettement qu'on va
servir je dirais en succession à noa noa
noa héritier et à côté de ça et bien il
y a j'allais dire l'économie réelle
l'économie du porte monnaie c'est à dire
ce qu'on regarde que l'on a dépensé pour
acheter un kilo de tomates à 4 euro un
kilo de fruits à 5 ou 6 euros on va pas
refaire évidemment l'éventail de toutes
ces hausses fantastique qui quand même
contredisent beaucoup la hausse moyenne
du pouvoir d'achat qu'on aurait
enregistré depuis depuis cinq ans la
réalité ça et jérôme rodriguez en est
évidemment la parfaite illustration
il raconte la vie de ces gens qui n'ont
rien vu changé depuis dix 2018 et qui
ont vu au contraire la vie la vie en
pire et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui qui sont des
survivants 1
comme je suis sociologue j'avais fait un
petit un petit portrait des des
catégories dans lesquelles on pouvait
émettre les français alors je vais
revenir il ya les gens sans rien du tout
donc qui sont sdf pour la majeure partie
les sans abri mais qui dorment dans la
rue tout à fait tout à fait 300 mille
quatre cent mille on ne sait plus
combien exactement ya les gens avec
presque rien qui sont pas très loin de
la première catégorie il ya les gens qui
ont très peu 1 à peine de quoi se
nourrir il ya les gens qui arrivent
quand même à se nourrir et à se loger à
peu près convenablement sans pouvoir
manger les 5 fruits et légumes qu'ils
coûtent trop cher qu effectivement c'est
eux or deux hors d'accès aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui peuvent comme un petit
peu partir en vacances et puis il ya les
gens très riches qui il faut bien le
reconnaître ne savent plus que faire
d'eux le riche elle sait qu'ils ont été
effectivement bien servi par la crise
sanitaire est ce qu'il n'ya pas trop de
clivage en france finalement je pense
que nous ne respectons pas la règle
fondamentale de la démocratie qui est la
règle de la justice sociale du partage
des rétributions juste des uns et des
autres il ya un fossé considérable qui
s'est aggravée avec la crise sanitaire
entre les français du haut et les
français les français du bas ce qu'on
appelle parfois un peu méchamment les
gens les gens de peu à la maison au
moins beaucoup de conscience de deux
situations qui sont encore une fois des
situations absolument inimaginable en
démocratie alors justement ces bons
chiffres de croissance ne permet-il pas
au gouvernement justement d'agiter le
drapeau d'une économie positive est ce
qu'on peut dire que ça les arrange à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
vous savez je crois qu'il faut savoir
qu'en réalité on n'a pas vraiment
retrouvé le bon niveau de croissance
d'avant la crise sanitaire 2019 donc là
on est dans des systèmes d'équilibrage
de rattrapage de compensation entre une
mauvaise année 2020 et une bonne année
de 2021 donc le redressement économique
est loin d'être d'être assuré 1
quand on voit le renchérissement des
matières premières
effectivement la hausse des coûts de
l'électricité qui pénalise beaucoup
beaucoup d'entreprises rien
malheureusement n'est encore assuré et
pour beaucoup de secteurs économiques
donc le pire n'est pas à exclure
devant nous alors société la campagne
présidentielle ne va pas se jouer
uniquement sur des thèmes elle va se
jouer sur des situations un rien ne
permet de dire que nous n'aurons pas
dans les prochaines semaines ou dans les
prochains mois une formidable crise une
formidable crise sociale qui couve quand
même depuis des années et michel
justement à ce que vous estimez que la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat est un thème
assez porté par les différents candidats
de la présidentielle
je crois qu'ils ont eu du mal à
considérer que c'était probablement un
thème beaucoup plus important que
l'immigration 1 je ne dis pas que les
l'immigration surtout quand elle est
massive ne constitue pas une
préoccupation pour un certain nombre de
français mais pour pour la majorité des
français encore une fois et c'est bien
qu'on ait ces images de gilet jaune pour
nous le rappeler pour la majorité
français c'est même pas la question du
pouvoir d'achat c'est le droit à
survivre le droit à l'existence le roi
encore une fois à une vie digne il est
quand même assez
pénible de constater qu'en 2022 on se
retrouve dans des situations
moyenâgeuse en tout cas qui nous
rappelle le mauvais 19e siècle c'était
une des promesses de campagne en
d'emmanuel napperons que plus personne
ne dorme dehors en france voilà alors
moi je pense que si on avait une
suggestion à faire puisqu'on a beaucoup
parlé du quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan
économique on a oublié un grand quoi
qu'il en coûte 1 quoi qu'il en coûte au
plan social donc qu'est ce que le
pouvoir va pouvoir faire en ces domaines
silva qui reste peu de temps il ya
tellement de secteur deux secteurs
sinistrés ria ce temps on a parlé il ya
quelques quelques jours elle et les
soignants les enseignants alors
d'horreur ce qui pose un certain nombre
de problèmes au plan au plan éducatif le
diplôme 1 on promet effectivement aux
soignants aux enseignants
le diplôme leur assurera de meilleures
conditions d'existence et on s'aperçoit
que ont les leurs avec les diplômes
parce que les diplômes ne sont pas
récompensés à la hauteur des efforts des
efforts fournis voilà donc je pense que
quelque part il voit aussi redonner du
sens et puis quand je disais tout à
l'heure que notre école va mal il faut
mais reconnu comme que depuis quelques
temps elle passe son temps à faire du
sanitaire plus que de l'instruction et
c'est sur ces mots qu'on va finir avec
vous mais cette fille mercy en tout cas
d'avoir été sur ce plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes éditorialistes sociologue
de profession se retrouveront samedi
prochain à samedi